tout d'abord je tiens à souhaiter une
bonne fête à toutes les femmes pour moi
cette journée permet une réflexion sur
la situation des femmes dans le monde je
pense aux femmes de notre continent qui
souffrent de la pauvreté et de la
violence ou la seule issue est
quelquefois de prendre la route vers
d'autres territoires comme la Guyane et
pourtant les statistiques ne sont pas
bonnes chez nous aussi la Guyane et le
territoire français avec le taux le plus
élevé de femmes battues selon le
ministère de l'intérieur avec un taux de
12,7 pour 1000 habitants cela est
inadmissible car nos femmes structurent
nos foyers car souvent elles sont
abandonnées par les pères en celui mars
je souhaite que la société guyanaise
réfléchissent à cette situation car cela
ajoute encore une mauvaise donnée pour
notre territoire et une nouvelle fois
bonne fête à toutes les femmes toutes
les femmes de Guyane et toutes les
femmes du monde entier